Speaker 1: Also want to invite you to participate
in the David Pakman show sub Reddit discussions.
You can find that at David Pakman dot com
slash Reddit. More than 30000 of our viewers
and listeners have already subscribed a couple
of posts. I want to briefly discuss that.
I spotted on the sub Reddit this morning.
One user said backlash to New Marzook recommendations
show why the left are bad at politics, arguing
the CDC changed mass guidelines to say you
can wear them indoors. And there has been
surprisingly, a lot of backlash to this from
our own side. Let me be straight. This is
a huge political win for Joe Biden. His agenda
is back to normal. And the quicker we get
back to normal, the better he looks. And in
terms Dems and the left as a whole, if he
were a Republican president, every single
Republican would be shouting through the rooftops
of the success of this and how we are basically
out of the pandemic. Instead, our own side
seems to be actively hampering our political
agenda by questioning the science of the decision.
And some cities and states are keeping massive
mandates in effect, regardless of the science.
So I think that this is a really, really good
point. And I'm going to do a commentary later
here. I'm going to talk about the mask forever
stuff. I won't preempt that because I'm going
to get into it. I think this is a really astute
commentary, which is some of the reaction
when the CDC said vaccinated people don't
really have to wear masks anywhere because
the vaccines are so effective and the spread
is cut so dramatically and the risk is just
so low. A better reaction would be it's incredible
how quickly Joe Biden got us to this point,
the left could have united and made this unilaterally
a win for Joe Biden. Look, Biden did covid
stimulus and he asked people to wear masks
for 100 days and all this different stuff
in vaccination. And now look at what the CDC
is able to say. Unfortunately, I think that
some on the left misplayed it by saying this
is crazy, even though we've been following
the CDC all along, we're going to keep mask
mandates. We're going to do all this different
stuff that frames it as not the win that it
really should be considered. And this is a
separate question from whether individuals
could, should or might choose to keep wearing
masks personally, which I think is perfectly
fine. And I'm going to address later. I think
that's a very astute commentary about a missed
opportunity by the left. Excellent post. Also
a number of posts, including this one about
Joe Rogan's comments that, quote, straight
white men are being silenced by, quote, WOAK
culture. I did a big rant about this yesterday
during a live stream where I talked about
the of the predecessors to so-called WOAK
culture, which is not a term I use, but it's
sort of a a follow on of Michel Fusco's postmodernist
analysis of literature, which has turned into
critical theory and a bunch of other things
which lead us to every narrative. Every narrative
has to be equally valued when I really don't
think that that's a good idea. And there are
some extremes, which may be Joe Rogan is alluding
to. But big picture Joe Rogan's comments about
what culture and people aren't going to be
able to go outside anymore because in the
past, some have been imprisoned and straight
white men won't be able to speak. It goes
cartoonishly too far. I ranted about it for
almost 15 minutes yesterday on a live stream.
We might pull that and make it a standalone
clip, but I do think that Joe Rogan goes too
far here in his comments. And I think most
of my audience tends to agree with that. But
join the discussion yourself on the sub Reddit
by going to David Pakman dotcom slash r e
d d i t. It's free. I'm selling you nothing
other than a free good time. OK, check
it out.